you ever think about being jockey that
mean just a question bro you're a tough
guy
yeah yeah you are never thought about
being jockey never I did your dad been
training more I have push I'm a train
more and a lot of people saw what you
did to me over here and I don't know
I'll take some [ __ ] I don't report it
because they didn't fight back by your
sense they would you said some [ __ ] and
I didn't fight back and you didn't take
away your black belt that's was hoping
for my my training has been upped even
though I've been busy yeah I feel I give
him a training because you've been
working so much but there are some
things that I know now that I would
never let you do so when I get my
underhooks on you I've been making a
crucial mistake you will never ever do
what you do me when I get on Oaks ok bro
ok I'm not saying I can beat me up oh
yeah but I'll fight back and I'm gonna
keep you busy
alright man get your hand in my face
probably treat you like your jockey I'm
not a jockey you're my jockey I'm the
big boy you know I've nobody's [ __ ]
jockey and I'm sure he's [ __ ] dude
you're my jock don't touch my hand dude
you know the main horse's name was big
brown this is my heir fame them I'm big
round you're the jockey no it's not many
times big brown one to [ __ ] that jockey
up hey you know yeah you fight I know in
your jockey dude have you heard of mr.
hands yeah you're looking at the horse
of mr. hands you're the guy that gets
[ __ ] you're the guy who's [ __ ]
icing icing icing dude don't make me
treat like a jockey I'm gonna turn
around I'm gonna mr. hanjo you know what
that means I'm a [ __ ] the ass dude
babe it even hang you know that just too
much all right hold on don't [ __ ] around
man dude we good we good I'll put a mr.
hanjo okay yeah okay you know right here
escalate this you know we're not we're
not
hey how hard I squeeze your hair that
was a really hurt yeah more tennis
lessons I'll call that a tear that's a
drug it's a troll yeah I tapped because
you were cranking my neck only cuz I
couldn't see the whole hockey move
I don't like that neck crank ooh nasty
you get me here and you do that you
can't break a neck Wow
however I dude there's only one way to
find out but I feel like you could break
your hand by squeeze in it I'm so much
tougher than you think hey you know 70%
we go hundo yeah I'm sure nothing like a
[ __ ] popsicle I honestly don't think
so dude that hurt I have [ __ ] finger
marks yeah that bird look at my finger
monkeys oh my god indentation yeah I'm
round I really done that 70% dude I was
on ha middle that's 70 a hundo
I'm breaking it was like Chiclets son
you're a bag of you are a gorilla
you're weird strong to you well you you
you beat some big guys up well that's a
bein quote your big guy for you my next
little tweet go home and really that's
our god I hate when that happens
guy tweet Jays neck to in San Jose and
then I figure
things more annoying than Jays like this
huh oh my god
hey justly meal I just got over a tweet
Mac well it's on the other side this is
on this side I've never had it this size
you gave me a new injury this is what
happens when we don't hang out we don't
see each other you around your actor
friends you give you lose your little
eye that's why I see a little froggy you
should bring more actors in here I got a
little froggy oh oh your shoulder hurts
I should know I was doing this I'm just
warming up you want another [ __ ]
round I'm gonna rip your wig off listen
I'm fantasize about taking her scalp
like that I would I would fight you and
I'll fight you now dude I'll tell you
don't want to hear I don't I can't doing
I don't need room dude I don't have any
room yeah you're you're you're you're
[ __ ] doing your [ __ ] jujitsu when
you I'm not you know I'm not even
responding you're not getting my neck
again I'll tell you that much yeah I'll
tell you what man these jockeys fix your
[ __ ] hair
jockeys stupid-looking my hair is dyed
is it [ __ ] us how did he get wide some
water you see what happens
yeah she was a jockeys little cocky no
don't call me a jockey [ __ ] strong
I got a tight green shirt on too I only
tapped that quickly cuz I'm afraid I'm
gonna hurt my neck yeah I don't know
dude don't ever [ __ ] my hair up again
cuz the only problem in jujitsu
get caught in the neck thing you can't
have long hair dude you do it why not
talk to the tea citibanks differ well
you right but he rises in cornrows I
refuse to do that no I don't do jujitsu
anymore anyways listen jockey Nikki shut
up dude imma tweak the other side what
are you gonna do dude if I stand up what
the [ __ ] you do bro are you sorry
[ __ ]
okay well this is nothing you're doing
this is not a okay
[Music]
you remember well I don't have a [ __ ]
Mac why he'd have time sprawl
Oh still there it's still there
eight six to one what's your bara he
came each other
I'll be there soon
damn it tweet my neck I warm up feel
like you Wanda honey right get tired
you've been doing that got some speed I
it's still better still there you know
y'all doubles crazy that double leg of
that disaster
alright don't don't drink with you
oh this all right she'll turn it this we
scrap bring that back in we got mad
about that well I heard my hair was
messy got mad I took it to another level
yeah hey strong boy yeah I had to pick
you up in the strong twirl you around
good Matt talk okay good not talking
yeah you are a [ __ ] gorilla friend I
didn't do it I didn't do the things I
wanted to do that wasn't well I know
it's okay so you're not getting you know
yay please contact her Gracie I stop
spray the Gracie Academy Boulevard 97 0
I didn't even I'm not gonna sprawl with
a [ __ ] couch there I hear you how do
you think I wanted to double it you know
the killer you're not getting a double a
[ __ ] no I don't want to do that mm
you're not getting the double dude but I
can't wait to go to Matt to America I
will move that table he's not allowed to
can't pick me haven't slam me no you
can't be picking people up and using
their strengths right path like
technique and strength bhop garlic yeah
you're not doing a post by the way all
over the long hill do that to anybody
any black bug you
that's good to see Ben can come see we
just stand up and Charlotte okay
Saturday I'll be a Cleveland we'll be
seeing any of that in a week right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]